bulle ou en tout cas en
principe. Comment l'industrie
doit s'adapter avec Marie
Michèle Lauzon.
- La dernière année, et surtout
le confinement, ont persuadé
Israel que son amoureuse
des dernières années était
la femme de sa vie.
L'été dernier, il lui a fait
la grande demande.
AUDREY MARQUIS
- Je pense que je m'y attendais.
Puis... il m'a quand même
surprise, quand il a sorti
la bague, aussi il était émotif,
alors on dirait que moi, ça m'a
comme surprise. (rires)
ISRAEL L'ITALIEN
- Elle était de glace.
Elle n'avait aucune réaction.
- Comme plusieurs amoureux,
ils n'avaient aucune idée
de l'aventure qui les attendait.
- On était aussi un peu naïfs
aussi dans ce temps-là de...
de croire que la COVID c'était
passé. On a tout de suite
réservé la salle en pensant
qu'on allait pouvoir être
130 personnes.
- Ils ont décidé d'abandonner
leur plan initial et d'organiser
leur propre mariage cet été.
- Il y a plein de fournisseurs
avec qui c'était compliqué.
La fleuriste, moi, ça m'a pris
tellement de temps à trouver
celle que j'ai tu sais... puis
au final, genre, encore là,
c'était comme, je suis tombée
sur la bonne.
- Leur fleuriste, c'est Anaïs.
ANAIS BERGERON CARON,
Designer florale
- En temps normal, mon atelier,
les fins de semaine, les jeudis,
vendredis, samedis, il est plein
de fleurs.
- La plupart de ses contrats
pour des mariages ont été
reportés. Son chiffre d'affaire
est passé de 200 000$ à 20 000$
l'an dernier.
- J'ai trouvé ça dur, j'ai
pleuré un petit peu. Puis à
un moment donné, tu sais, c'est
comme dans toutes choses, c'est
comme un deuil, à un moment
donné, tu t'y fais. J'ai misé
sur le positif puis j'ai passé
un été avec mes enfants,
puis j'ai retrouvé le bonheur
de faire des fleurs tu sais
juste pour faire des fleurs
et non parce qu'il y des clients
qui attendent un résultat
de l'autre bord.
- Toutes les facettes
de l'industrie du mariage
ont dû s'adapter, changer
leur approche.
EMMANUELLE BLANCHET,
Propriétaire EMAN B DESIGN
- On se ramasse à planifier
comme un A-B-C-D de qu'est-ce
qu'on veut faire.
- Emmanuelle confectionne
des robes de mariage sur mesure
depuis 8 ans. Elle a dû
réaménager son appartement
pour y travailler.
EMMANUELLE BLANCHETTE,
propriétaire, Emmane B. Design
- Le salon était ici avant,
avec la télévision ici.
- Avec un nouveau collègue
de travail, son fils de 2 ans.
- On prend une pause.
- Ce qui l'a marquée au cours
des derniers mois : l'angoisse
vécue par les fiancées.
- Moi, j'ai eu énormément
de clientes qui pleuraient
au téléphone. Je me suis
connectée avec une psychologue
dans le fond afin de leur... les
aider à les soutenir. Tu sais,
quand t'as plusieurs clientes
qui... qui pleurent au téléphone
à cause qu'ils ont de la peine,
qui vivent de la déception...
- Mona Salehi connaît bien
les émotions qui habitent
les nouveaux mariés. Comme
notaire, elle officialise
des unions depuis
plus de 10 ans.
MONA SALEHI, notaire
- En mars 2020, on
a complètement arrêté de faire
des mariages ici.
- En septembre dernier,
elle a complètement réaménagé
sa terrasse personnelle
pour être en mesure de célébrer
des mariages.
- On a fait le toit et tout ça
pour prévoir s'il pleut et aussi
laisser beaucoup d'espace
d'aération pour que les
fluctations... l'air circule
quand même.
- Et aucun détail n'a été laissé
au hasard.
- On a prévu ça :
(bruit tambour) pour donner
l'ambiance qui peut manquer
en raison du nombre réduit
de participants dans le mariage
donc on prévoit ça pour donner
un petit peu de pep, de joie.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Une centaine d'amoureux ont pu
célébrer leur union ici au cours
des derniers mois. Un événement
privé, intime que plusieurs
couples s'apprêtent à vivre
cette année devant l'incertitude
qu'engendre la pandémie.
MARIE-PIER LUSIGNAN,
Planificatrice événementiel
- Les gens qui ont décidé
de maintenir leur mariage
cet été, ont décidé de se marier
dans la simplicité,
dans l'imprévu.On revient à :
l'important, c'est notre union,
notre amour.
- C'est ce que comptent faire
Audrey et Israël, un petit
mariage, avec quelques invités,
dans la cour du chalet familial.
- Ça fait deux mois là qu'elle
traîne dans la garde-robe...
- Le 31 juillet prochain, elle
pourra enfin mettre sa robe.
Ici Marie-Michelle Lauzon,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.